[Music]
it's Friday and that means it's time for
Oh Friday folly some strange coverage of
stranger things a backlash over a new
Little Mermaid and the rise again of the
murse
joining us with all the details Raymond
Arroyo foxnews contributors all right
Raymond Netflix's stranger things I saw
the first two two seasons tens of
millions of people have watched this and
now there's a controversy over the the
sexuality of one of the young boys yeah
in season three now I'll tell you will
buyer who you remember is the central
character in this whole story and he's
one of the young characters on the show
well he did have seen this season in
three and some in the media at least
thought it raised questions about the
character sexuality now bear in mind
though character is 12 years old
he's been playing games with his friends
but now he only wants to talk about
girls what you're just throwing
everything in for one you could swap
spit with some stupid girl
I was not stupid so I'm I thought you
don't like girls I mean what did you
think really we were never gonna get
girlfriends we're just gonna sit in my
basement all day and play games for the
rest of our lives
[Music]
yes I did now obviously this is an
innocent scene okay about a child going
through growing pains but people in
social media started saying will Myers
is gay then a reporter at The Wrap
confronted the 14 year old actor who
plays will know what she lapped the boy
there in the scene and asked him the
question the actor said I kind of just
interpret it like he's not ready to grow
up he still wants to be a kid and play
in the basement like he did in old times
why must we sexual that's the kids Laura
and in this case one of the best-known
kids in the world because of this
television show in the success of it
well everyone should know that that if
you haven't seen the show it's it takes
us back to the 80s and seven right
seventies eighties earliest and
everything seems a lot simpler in many
ways in the 80s and there's a big hunger
for simpler times right a simpler thing
right this is strange of simpler times
where it was old there was a little
maybe a little more in a sense this is
the adolescence of America though Lord
we have adults who are still adolescents
projecting their anxieties their
sexuality on to these young characters
their kids and it's a kid's character
and I love that Noah slap later posted
on Instagram smoosh snap he later
deleted this he said for me will being
gay or not is besides the point stranger
things as a show about a bunch of kids
who are outsiders and find each other
because they've been bullied in some way
or are different does being sensitive or
a loner or a teenager who likes
photography or a girl with red glasses a
red hair and big glasses make you gay
that's a profound child shall lead them
he's got more wisdom than these adults
asking to separate that's a profound
comment because some kids are just look
whiter and they're a little more
sensitive maybe they're a little
artistic and adults Russia and they say
you must be this or you are good and
they put you down and let them grow up
and make their own decisions and that's
what I really don't like everyone is
trying to sexualize children and I think
for their own you know agenda and I
don't like that at all Laura it was
reported that there was a huge backlash
against Disney's announcement that they
were casting a black actress and singer
Halle Bailey he
the lead of the new live-action Little
Mermaid now the washington post b ET and
other outlets reported on the hashtag
not my aerial movement now that's the
name of the Mermaid Arielle it was
supposedly driven by racists upset that
a black actress was playing a white
cartoon character well it turns out much
of the uproar was over two tweets one of
which came from a now suspended dummy
account and the not my Ariel hashtag was
created by those defending the
multiracial casting one of the
Washington Post pieces even tied the
supposed bassist uprising to Donald
Trump I don't know what the controversy
is here this is a cartoon character
it's a Caucasian mermaid who lives under
the sea it's all fiction
who cares if she's white or green or
blue or yellow in a live-action version
what was the origins of the story it was
a Norwegian Hans Christian Andersen I
agree it doesn't matter Laura Pearl
Bailey and Cab Calloway did an all-black
version of Hello Dolly there were not
riots in Broadway it didn't matter
people people can interchange that's
fine my problem is they tried to whip up
racial hatred I guess to draw attention
to this project
now Disney is doing a lot of these kind
of lame-o live-action recreations
they're doing Lion King this week which
is a frame for frame recreation of the
old cartoon now we have an exclusive
preview for Ingraham angle viewers this
scene is so powerful watch when it comes
to children again
I'm the lioness I'm just gonna protect
our cubs you call that the circle of
strife circle is drive that I'll take
Nancy is gonna be something will fossa
anyway apparently friends had it right
all those years ago Laura when they said
men really do love their bags you know I
make fun all you want this is a great
bag okay and it's as handy as it is
becoming just because you don't
understand something doesn't make it
wrong
all right so from now on you guys are
gonna have to get used to the fact that
Joey comes with a bag all right well
Joey may come with a bag he does sit
later but I doubt many guys will be
carrying these things now fashion houses
are premiering Merces purses for men on
their runways Dior and Mays leave it all
and more are selling crossbody bags and
clutches for guys now Laura lacrosse
players and even Nick Jonas has been
spotted with these things yes that is a
leather clutch it's hard to see there
he's holding a leather clutch
I guess backpacks are out and apparently
Merces are in even for backpacks
if you've graduated from college okay
and you're a guy that's pretty in law
you're hiking oh you're like a in sport
if you're nationals right if you're if
you're do sports for a living then
backpack then you can do it if you're
going to job everyday somehow the
backpacks you want the angry babies you
want the old briefcase I think I can
bring back the briefcase let's do that
let's bring back the briefcase don't
write to them those old wardrobe bags I
don't mind I don't mind satchels if
you're a news actual that would be a bag
that is appropriate for a man to carry
but yeah in the 1800's these dainty
cross belt and clutches what's next
we're gonna have to wear shoes to match
the Doorn things well I don't I think
it's all it's all the gender bending
this is all capitalizing on the bad look
and it makes you look to coin a phrase
that Donald Trump uses all the time
makes it a very weak no bag here stay
safe in New Orleans I will this weekend
we're praying for everybody everyone's
worried and New Orleans and please stay
safe